truly free when I was younger I was born
in the wrong body which means that I am
transgender nikkietutorials
comes out as transgender sharing this
with you today is first of all oh my god
this feels so liberating you have no
idea the 25 year old makeup artist
revealed the news in a video called I'm
coming out that she uploaded to her
YouTube channel which boasts over 12
million subscribers today I am taking
back my own power but Nicki admits her
decision to come out wasn't on her terms
it is vile and it is gross and I know
you are watching this this one's for you
I hope you can stick nice on it she says
she didn't plan on releasing the private
information to the public just yet
but she was inevitably forced to I have
been blackmailed by people that wanted
to leak my story to the press
Nicki also got candid about her
relationship with her fiance Dillon who
popped the question in Italy back in
August 2019 now Dillon is a very very
special guy and I've never met anyone
like Dillon he is truly the most
kind-hearted man ever revealing he
recently found out the truth Dillon and
I we clicked and he didn't know he knows
now Dillon knows about my past but I
wish I'd told him sooner everything felt
so magical so good that I was afraid to
lose him if I would tell my full story
and at the point where I told him my
full story of course he was shocked but
that is a private matter that we're
dealing with and that I'm so proud of
that we're able to deal with over the
years Nicki's channel has largely
revolved around the power of makeup but
she told her fans it was time to explore
the power of me and in being open with
her subscribers Nicki hopes to inspire
others to do the same this world
leads us the video has fans and fellow
Beauty vloggers praising her for her
bravery and honesty desi Perkins
tweeted I'm so proud of you while a
fellow trans beauty at Nikita Dragon
tweeted in part I am so proud of you I
know how hard it is to see you out and
living your truth has brought me to
tears you don't know how many people
you're inspiring and helping by sharing
your story I am one of them after all
these years I'm sharing it with you now
but nothing changes because at the end
of the day on my channel my number one
passion is the power of makeup
[Music]